as we saw yesterday there's a woman who
showed up to Congress
to put a human face on the opioid
epidemic that most of our politicians
certainly the liberal politicians but
many establishment politicians broadly
just don't seem to care very much about
her name is Rebecca kiesling her sons
Caleb and Kyler were killed along with
another friend of a fentanyl overdose
this was just a few years ago her sons
were 20 and 18 years old and
and Mrs kiesling is asking why won't the
Congress do anything about this epidemic
I lost my two sons
um
on July 29 29th of 2020.
um it was absolutely A Perfect Storm
there were there was also a 17 year old
girl
Sophia Harris who died along with them
and the drug dealer Lorenzo Brabo was
spared by Narcan
and he ended up getting 8 to 15 years
for killing three people he was another
addict and so because he survived they
had leads to who he got it from and they
actually could try to start tracing it
back and the
law enforcement made it clear to me that
this fentanyl came from Mexico it came
from our Southern border
it's an amazing line it's an amazing
moment one of the most impressive
moments I've ever seen in Congressional
testimony this mother who lost two of
her sons so young
completely preventable deaths deaths
caused not just by teenage
irresponsibility which is basically
Universal but by the decisions of people
in Congress to keep that border open and
to go soft on drugs
this is this is not just something
that's happening naturally and you can't
prevent it in the year two thousand
twenty thousand Americans died of drug
overdoses
today 100 000 Americans more than a
hundred thousand Americans die every
year from drug overdoses
5x today what we saw just a little over
20 years ago that's not just an accident
that's just not just the the natural
changes of politics that is because of
specific policies that's because
Democrats and some establishment
Republicans won't close the border
that's because Democrats and some squish
Republicans want to go soft on drugs not
just not enforce the law but actually
stop enforcing not just not enforce the
law but but loosen up the law liberalize
the drug laws make it easier for drug
dealers to Peddle poison that's why this
is happening
and what do we hear we say well look we
know that fentanyl is pouring across the
border they say well what do you want to
do you want to stop those future dreamer
Americans from coming across yes yeah I
want to stop the drug cartels from
poisoning America across the border say
well don't you know that when we enforce
border policies parents are separated
from their children that woman says well
you know my children were separated from
me too
and I'm an American what about me what
about me
it's not a complicated issue Ronald
Reagan made this point in the 80s he
said illegal immigration is not
complicated it's illegal end of story
this is not we we we're talking about
gangs and drugs and breaking the law in
El Salvador this week
El Salvador was able to cut its murder
rate by 58 and it wasn't all that
complicated it was actually pretty
simple
if you arrest the criminals the murder
rate goes down
how do you prevent these these drug
deaths 100 000 plus per year
you enforce the immigration policies and
you enforce the drug laws
not rocket science we can do it
the Liberals and the squishes in the
Republican party don't want to do it
this is the consequence okay that's fine
they have their reasons for it they want
cheap labor they want they want
foreigners to flood the country
they think that people have a right to
do drugs that will kill them okay that's
that's what then look the victims in the
face
and look look at the consequences of
those actions and don't say well it's
just this is the tides of history no
it's because of specific decisions being
made by very very irresponsible
politicians
the fentanyl problem is not just a
little uptick in drugs in America it is
something we have never seen before
Sentinel is just pure poison
and Fentanyl is pouring across our
border
as part of a concerted effort to weaken
our country
by Foreign actors by our enemies by
China to begin with and then through
Mexico because they know that
effectively we don't have a board U.S
Customs and Border Protection
who were assigned to the Andrade Port of
Entry in California
Justice just hit a new Port record
by seizing nearly one million dollars of
Fentanyl and meth
that was in one car they were hiding it
in the in the gas tank
one million dollars worth of Fentanyl
and meth
how many people not only could that
amount of drugs have killed how many
people would that fentanyl have killed
had that car made it through
we don't know
chances are
if you don't know somebody who has died
of a fentanyl overdose
in the last five years
I promise you you know somebody who
knows somebody
I know people who died of these
overdoses people I grew up with
everybody does and it's not like I grew
up in Breaking Bad okay I didn't grow up
in some totally drug-ridden Community I
grew up in a pretty nice suburb in New
York it's everywhere
and so we can celebrate all good CBP was
able to catch a million dollars worth of
this stuff
that's what we caught
imagine what's getting through sometimes
the liberals who try to make excuses
about this they say yeah it's good
Border Protection is working we were
able to catch these people
they'll say well we were able to catch
the criminals that were trying to sneak
over illegally
who usually are then just released back
into the public or they'll say oh we
were able to catch the drugs yeah
imagine how much in the way of drugs is
getting through you don't have to
imagine because a hundred thousand plus
Americans every year are dying from it a
5x increase
the rest of the show continues now you
don't want to miss it become a member at
dailywire.com use code Knowles at
checkout
you get two months free on all annual
plans
[Music]